rachel maddow
my doppelganger i try not to go after
her too much
you know i feel a certain kinship to her
might be an actual kinship i don't know
we've never taken a dna test rachel
maddow
has
spread
misinformation about
the coronavirus
it means that instead of the vaccine
being able excuse me it means for
instead of the virus being able to hop
from person to person to person to
person spreading and spreading sickening
some of them but not all of them and the
ones that it doesn't stick and don't
know they have it and then they give it
even more people because they didn't
recognize they were
right instead of the virus being able to
hop from person to person to person
potentially mutating and becoming more
virulent and drug-resistant along the
way now we know that the vaccines work
well enough that the virus
stops with every vaccinated person
a vaccinated person gets exposed to the
virus
virus does not infect them the virus
cannot then use that person to go
anywhere else
it cannot use a vaccinated person as a
host to go get more people
that means
the vaccines will get us to
the end of this
if we just go fast enough to get the
whole population vaccinated
so what she said is not true and it's
now been contradicted by the public
health authorities this is a great
example because
ms maddow and i might bear some passing
similarity okay some passing resemblance
and yet she says false things and
doesn't get censored i say true things
that now even the public health
officials admit are true
and i do get censored why is that what's
going on here why
has that been the case for the whole of
the
lockdown and the pandemic and whatever
and why does that continue to be
the case more on that in one second
first though
no one wants to cut corners on what's
important and few things matter more
than a good night's rest
bowl and branches signature sheets feel
so soft and light you will forget that
you are not actually sleeping on a cloud
no you're just sleeping on sheets they
just happen to be the best sheets in the
world i really love them
i've had the opportunity to sleep on
really fancy sheets when i go to fancy
hotels which has happened two or three
times in my life at least and it's
really great and you think why can't i
do this every single night well you can
with bowlin branch their bestseller for
a reason buttery soft lightweight
organic cotton in a classic sateen weave
for sheets that get softer and softer
over time not too hot not too cool
i got these as a wedding present for
myself
i have given these to friends and family
they're just absolutely wonderful
experience the best sheets you've ever
felt at bowlingbranch.com get 15 off
your first set of sheets when you use
promo code michael mich ael at checkout
that's bowlin branch b-o-l-l and branch
dot-com promo code michael b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch dot com promo code michael so
rachel maddow has gone on air and said
that the vaccines 100
prevent people from contracting
the virus one and transmitting the virus
to 100 the virus just stops at that
person and that's why if enough people
get the vaccine the virus will just
completely stop now i know that
apparently
i can be censored and have been censored
on youtube for pointing out that this is
not true which is why i would recommend
you go to the audio podcast the apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
there
and you will get the uh completely
uncensored you won't have to deal with
youtube or any of the other big tech
sensors there
but
you don't need to just take my word for
it
all of the major public health officials
have
directly contradicted what rachel maddow
said
what they can't do anymore is prevent
transmission you know we didn't have
vaccines that block transmission we got
vaccines to help you with your health
but they only slightly reduce the
transmissions we need a new
new way of doing the vaccine the level
of virus in the nasal pharynx
of a person who's vaccinated and
infected
is the same level as the level of virus
in the nasal parents of an unvaccinated
person reports from our international
colleagues including israel suggests
increased risk of severe disease amongst
those vaccinated early and if you look
at israel
which has always been a month to a month
and a half
ahead of us they are seeing
a waning of immunity not only against
infection
but against hospitalizations
and to some extent death a booster might
actually be an essential part
of the primary regimen that people
should have
so there you have it
rachel maddow says one thing
the public health officials directly
contradict what she said
in this case only much later only long
after the fact but it does happen to be
the case that what the public health
officials have said in this specific
case is true what rachel maddow said was
completely wrong
so my question the babylon be asked this
question yesterday
why is she not being kicked off of
twitter for misinformation
she has spread much more misinformation
about kovid than marjorie taylor green
has why does marjory taylor green get
kicked off of social media but rachel
maddow does not
why does this show
which has an extraordinarily good record
in terms of uh calling the shots on this
virus
why does this show
more i hate you know i hate to say i
told you so you know i hate to toot my
own horn
probably more accurate than
almost any other show
if not every single other show
on
on the coronavirus from day one
how come we get censored but rachel mata
who's been dead wrong for most of it
she doesn't get censored because i have
actually the answer to that
it is not about what you say
it is about
who is saying it
it isn't it actually it is not now nor
has it ever been
about what is
said about the virus
it is about
who does the saying hold up did you like
that clip don't be honest don't just
flatter me
i hope you did if you did ring that bell
subscribe you'll get the notifications
if you really want to get the
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe there maybe leave a five star
review i don't know
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you